welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens today breaking down the
first episode of what if nebula joined
the Nova Corp this episode is written by
Matthew Chanty and directed by Steven
Frank who created a comic book that's
just as Eerie so I'm so excited to go
over this episode with y'all and
celebrate another badass project for
nebula but first the merch drop we have
some merch inspired by what if so go
over to nerd rot. shop to go check that
out we opened with the Marvel Studio
logo slightly different from last
seasons because it started with the full
lawn Marvel intro this one begins with
the comic pages and into the
breaststroke Marvel logo the last time
we got this logo I believe was an I am
Gro and that's also the last time we
technically saw the Watcher in the
finale of season 2 the intro is ominous
it's silent during the logo but starts
to ease into an uncanny Echo like the
deep dark sounds of a Barren City faint
noises of what's left follow and we
taken to a rainy deep teal City skyline
this we find out later is xandar last we
heard of xandar in the MCU Thanos
destroyed it retrieving the Power Stone
but we never actually saw it happen but
we did hear Thor bring it up to the
Guardians in Infinity war dandar is also
a major part of Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 1 and we'll get back into that in
a second when we get further into the
show this episode is completely modeled
after Blade Runner specifically the 1982
one starring our favorite person in the
world Harrison Ford oo yummy yummy the
writers of wh if at the what if event at
the Disney Studio Lot that we all
attended mentioned a lot of these
episodes are fashioned after their
favorite 80s movies so I think the idea
that The Grandmaster episode is
fashioned after Mad Max is no surprise
we have the'80s icons and what if pater
quill attacked Earth's Mightiest heroes'
80s Kurt Russell Hank Pim voiced by the
80s icon Michael Douglas the list goes
on this is going to be a nostalgic
season this scene though is fashioned
after Blade Runner at the very end when
it's raining the Deep teal tone after
Chris dies and Roy's hunting Deckard
there are so many Blade Runner homages
that I'll call them as I see them as we
go throughout the episode we open with
the skyline of xandar just like in Blade
Runner the first scene we see in that
movie is the Los Angeles Skyline dark
but lit by the flames and distant lights
in the city it's like the Peter Pan r at
Disneyland that has all the little
lights everywhere it's not exactly like
eye for eye the same shot but it's very
similar and we're going for the same
tone just on xandar the same Neon Lights
illuminate the gritty dirty Alleyway
like streets again this is Blade Runner
and nebula is our Deckard but she's
standing over yondu's dead body like
Gaff after he killed Roy nebula still
voiced by Karen Gillan narrates this
like The Usual Suspects and she says
this right here a place where everyone's
luck eventually runs out even yandu he's
clearly been shot in the back and the
body Ain't Even Cold Yet you can see the
smoke leaving the wound a bigger hole in
his back than in PR's
gut I like how they even got yandu scars
on the side of his head design in this
episode what's funny is when yandu was
on xandar during Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 1 he didn't have that fin yet he
didn't get the longer prototype fin
until volume two when he was hostage and
Groot and kagin had to steal it for him
nebula saers from the Shadows like a
black cat in her Nova cor uniform ooh
the writers really liked working with
Karen Gillan so they wanted to Fashion
an episode around her and I love that
because Karen is nebula and nebula is
Karen they even animated that Sassy
unimpressed dance that nebula has right
when nebula questions who killed yandu a
bright light beams behind her and it's
the rest of the Novae on their ropes
crashing down one novacore Officer says
this nebula so she's just an average
Nova cor officer like John C Riley's
character in the first Guardians movie
at the beginning it's Saul the dinarian
Novae Soldier he died fighting Rodin
during the Battle of xandar and
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 1 as
opposed to his character in this episode
of what if he was highly respected he
was also really funny he had a code of
honor with the Nova cor sa Force feeds
everyone a false narrative without even
organizing a full-on investigation in
this episode waving yandu off as a petty
criminal which is exactly what he said
about Quil coming to xandar in the first
Guardian movie assuming it was all a
trick this is already following the '
80s good cop bad cop organization themes
this feels like dark blue with Kurt
Russell or Copland with Silvester still
own or even Training Day with Ethan Hawk
and Denzel Washington if you like this
you'll probably like those movies Saul
says this I don't need black order trash
telling me how to do my job the black
order was thanos's gang also referred to
as the children of Thanos they were
never called the black order in the MCU
that I know of just the children of
Thanos in the leadup to Infinity War
marketing materials referred to them as
the black order this is how we knew
black Dwarfs was renamed Co obsidian
because in recent Comics the group was
known as Co obsidian as a unit we know
in the MCU included ebony ma Proxima
midnight Co obsidian and corvus glaive
and also technically at one point at
home gamor and nebula when they fought
alongside their father fun fact they're
called the black order because each of
their name has something to do with
night and darkness also they bring
unyielding power to the cosmos that part
I made up but also it's kind of true
regardless this is our first indicator
that nebula was once working for her
father as we already knew from her past
but instead of aligning with her sister
and the Guardians she wanted up on
xandar nebula argues former black order
and interjects that she got three stars
just like Saul and this is a reminder
that the xandar novacore officers have
three stars on their armor representing
three sons of xandar we don't really see
the process they go through to become
novacore officers but I assume that's
what nebula is talking about nebula gets
into her hover police car that I don't
think was at all featured on xandar this
is a ship modeled after the police car
and Blade Runner the spinner it is even
equipped with butterfly doors then we
get to the opening scene for what if
with the Watcher narrating of course is
still voiced by Jeffrey Wright our
number one man it begins the same way as
last season did but when it cracks after
seeing Captain America Steve Rogers we
see gamor as where Monda used to be a
portal created by strange Supreme where
Doctor Strange used to be I think this
may be cohort's episode above strange is
toala from last season then Ultron
vision from last season next to chachala
it looks like young Steve Rogers we now
have Heim Dale from last season above
heale is Thor blue Loki AKA Loki as the
full Frost GI from last season Peggy
Carter the Hydra logo zombie Wanda the W
woo Spider-Man the eyeball of Bruce
changing into the Hulk in the last
season then it shifts we got Cort nebula
yandu topaz all to say these shots and
cracks in the universes are pieces from
last season and this season creating
infinite realities infinites to the
unknown the past present and future of
our realities have no Authority here not
even the man who watches it has complete
control we're ascending into chaos and
parallel universes to our own but
shifted off its access a mirror to the
universe something that's always changed
and expand and can't have the same
reflection let's get into this before I
go crazy our guide and the ending of the
intro are the same a silhouette which we
got from last season of the Watchers big
old Noggin it's full of stars and
endless space like his view of reality
he brings us into the episode again
narrating of course all Quests for
Redemption begin in darkness which
immediately reminded me of Loki and how
he's at the end of time alone in
darkness but conquering his fear being
alone and protecting all the streams of
time and also Wanda collapsing Wonder
Gore under herself Zuri dying to save
tchala I'd argue Tony Stark in the cave
physical and metaphorical Darkness
Redemption isn't new for the MCU and
Guardians of the Galaxy nebula did try
to portray Thanos alongside Ronin but
here we see Ronin did all the betraying
and kick nebula out of the family
business along with killing Gamora she
floated in space like Gamora when she
petray Thanos and nebula blew her up
regardless nebula is founded by Nova
Prime and saves her by beaming her out
of space like their ships are known to
do Nova Prime is voiced by Julianne
Grossman here in the movie she was
played by Glenn Close the novacore
headquarters is identical to how it
looks in Guardians of the Galaxy with
the iconic novacore symbol the novacore
motto is seek the light be the light
never stray from its path which was
never mentioned before then Ronin attack
attack xandar cue the Battle of xandar
this still did happen in our reality but
with the help from the ravagers brought
together by quill there wasn't really
anyone to help additionally Thanos fell
to Ronin and Ronin was still on a
mission to take down xandar in this
reality he never screamed his plan in
front of nebula I assume so he just
destroyed her family and her having a
bad habit is like having your own
personal Nemesis a little Goblin sitting
upon your shoulder constantly tempting
you to post that hot take but with fume
you get that Goblin out of there once
and for all that's because fume was made
to help replace your bad habits with
good ones that you're free to enjoy it's
an Innovative a war dominated device
with no electronics no vapor and no
harmful chemicals fume is completely
natural and uses all natural ingredients
to give you a burst of delicious
flavored air fume is super fidgety which
is helpful for distressing while you
break your old habit each device has an
adjustable airflow dial and is designed
with movable parts and magnets and the
new Solano fume is made with a premium
Walnut barrel and an onyx Coen
mouthpiece that has a slightly softer
finish if you're feeling fancy and I'm
always feeling fancy using fuse F gives
you a nice moment just for yourself
especially when it's cold out or the air
is brisk Maple pepper warms me up but
like in my brain it's a maple pepper
thing trust me we all put off stopping
our bad habits because it's hard but
switching to fume is easy enjoyable and
even fun fume has served over 150,000
customers and has thousands of success
stories and there's no reason you can't
be one of them join fume and
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to trium.vira
today that's TR f.com and use code new
rockstars to save an additional 10% off
your order today here Nova Prime decided
to put xandar within a planetary Shield
but in the movie they put a shield
around the dark Aster they linked up and
made a barricade that didn't really work
in a specific comic The Watcher did get
involved and save xandar by placing them
in a biosphere and this could be a sort
of call out to that the shield doors are
like the inner workings of a processor
when they close the shields on xandar
it's different than the ones on wakanda
this is like a Sci-Fi futuristic
computer security processing chip
hackers neb NE notes has been 5 years in
and isolation has made the people of
xandar wild clearly yandu and nebula
have been working together from Saul's
quick insult of yandu earlier and nebula
being a person of Honor now I would
assume yandu is like an informant for
nebula at times like quill did for Roman
day maybe nebula is like him and yandu
is like quill she plays yondu's iconic
whistle to find the arrow then catches
it we know the arrow is used with your
heart and your feelings but I don't
think nebula has even those two things
good to note though that it still works
if you just use Yu's voice the hearts
are still in the Hologram nebul opens an
entire database on information on
yondu's Arrow a green ball illuminates
an orb of instructions it's like
schematics with similar prints as the
closing shield on xandar when Nova Prime
begins scheming and switches to the
other line I know it's just for dramatic
effect but I love the changing of the
colors to Red it is so good when nebula
gets off the phone with Nova Prime the
sound changes to something distinct from
Blade Runner it's like the reverberation
of a synthesizer I won't let you
down nebula Dives down onto the streets
of xandar and it's giving 2099 from
across the spiderverse and it looks like
the inspiration would be directly from
sidm inside this casino it's bumping bro
is working at table and we see the money
he picks up we rarely see currency in
the MCU unless it's digitally given but
these Cosmic dice like ones are written
in xandarian these brown coins are
probably the equivalent to poker chips
we see meat cutting fish and it's just
superb the slot machine is clearly a
loser but we see our man Drax pissed
about losing he's next to old people
that have the jump on him to control him
also all the machines look like they
were designed by the grandm then we meet
corg the bartenders still voiced by taoa
Titi nebula says is the big man in a
subtle jab but also probably a pseudonym
on this planet because he's very small
and you know how like the dawn always
goes by like a funny name the casino
resembles the casino from the first
Black Panther movie they're different
styles for sure but I wouldn't be
surprised if this is where they got
their inspiration we see our favorite
background character Howard the Duck
still played by Seth Green he loves
playing cards just like in Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 with kagin those cards do
resemble the cards that they were
playing with they just have different
designs Howard's outfit is very scummy a
purple suit with zebra print accents and
a gold chain this is literally a
Halloween costume you can actually buy
at like Spirit Halloween he jokes and
asks if nebula wants megabytes because
she's a cyborg and he's so freaking
funny so we learned via cord this is an
old city Mainframe core a unit b42 the
hod project sh sanitation department
metadata unpaid parking tickets Rush
Hour statistics source code for the
shield generator even an actual kitchen
sink neb is now on her way to see yon
Rock yon Rock was the piece of crab cre
that actually worked with Ronin to wipe
out the Scrolls he wiped Carol's
memories and made her believe the
Scrolls were terrorists and manipulated
for a while at the end of Captain Marvel
he's blasted back to hollow with a
message and that's the last we see of
him but nebula mentions this is someone
that's infiltrated zindar and systems
before in Star Force on the rise this is
a prequel to Captain Marvel where they
actually find themselves on xandar and
yonr was tasked to infiltrate sigil a
zarian controlled planet to get the
schematics for a weapon so he's
infiltrated zarian systems before for
sure in this universe nebula arrested
yonr for it additionally we should all
remember yon Rog worked with Ronin
because they're both PR and wanted to
wipe out more Scrolls we see y rog's
prison she and it's all xandarian
letters that don't really make anything
out it's just miscellaneous numbers and
letters everywhere the prison that homes
yog is actually the kilm from the first
Guardians of the Galaxy movie this was
the facility run by the Nova cor but it
wasn't on xandar this one looks like
it's on xandar nebula hands off her
xandarian weapons to this sort of droid
in the first movie novacore and their
Associates on killing did the processing
but there were some robots assisting
them occasionally throughout the movie
we're now inside the novacore prison and
the prisoners are yelling at nebula just
like they did her sister it's funny cuz
she's the cop that put them all in there
but Gamora just portrayed and ruined
everyone's lives with Thanos so it's
kind of like Poetic Justice we met yon
Rock who is still voiced and played by
Jude Law he's wearing the same prison
clothes the Guardians wore in the
earlier movie nebula shoots the lock
screen that keeps yonr in and it looks
like the shards of the intro to what if
the prison looks hella dark and scary
unlike the one in Guardians that one
looked actually really fun nebula
releases all the inmates with the tablet
in the movie I think rot just released
them by ripping out the important cables
in the wall she knocks out a scroll and
there are other Scrolls around them
fighting for their lives which feels
wrong that they're all locked up and Y
on rog's the one being released they
escape the prison in the hover police
car that flies away the exact same way
the Blade Runner one does even the top
of the building they break into is
exactly like the Ty rail Corporation
Tower from Blade Runner they walk to the
data core in the water I assume this is
like the xandarian world mine from the
comics which houses all knowledge of
xandar and the Nova cor though this is
more of the xandarian world mine it's
giving the Supreme intelligence from the
first Captain Marvel movie even the
water is included the Mainframe core
says Omega class cybernetic organism
detected normally in Marvel Omega levels
refer to a mutant with one single ime
power in this case I think it must refer
to how advanced nebula is as a cyborg
but also an organic being nebula
connects herself to the main frame and
we've seen her do this throughout the
MCU before but then yonr betrays her and
steals the information from her head
which is still attached to the main
frame so it recognizes the threat which
is Tethered to nebula so it's about to
implode her eyes turn red which reminds
me of when they turn bright when she's
taken apart by Thanos a horrible scene
then the scene turns red the color
switches from Heavenly to like garbage
yellow and green mixed with red accents
it's all beautiful and horrible at the
same time nebula's on edge edge of a
small sewage drop off where the water
exits it's revealed that it's all been a
setup and yon Rog is working with Nova
Prime I guess the 5 years of isolation
just really messed up Nova Prime she
became a crazy psychopath woman they
beat nebula with cattle PRS which they
beat Peter with in the first Guardians
movie when he wanted his music back also
if I hear nebula Scream one more time in
this universe I I'll lose my mind I'm so
tired of this woman being destroyed and
torn into pieces she jumps off the cliff
and this went from Blade Runner to
Emperor's New Groove real quick this
also isn't her first time falling off an
edge of anything when NE lays on the
casino table being fixed up we get some
xandarian code we tried translating
everything that had text but each time
we came up with like gibberish it was
just miscellaneous like xandarian like
words and numbers which which is fine
it's still the xandarian language it
just doesn't really make anything Howard
calls them rock paper scissors a call
back to earlier seeing them play Rock
Paper Scissors on the form of rock paper
scissors I like that when you play Rock
Paper Scissors you can always end it
with shoot and you know how are the
Ducks there and he could be the shoot
cuz people shoot
ducks nebula wears johu fin whistle an
arrow in his duster she just like
grabbed it off his dead body dead body
still in the street it just doesn't I
don't know why she took it she didn't
need to take the jacket it looks cool
then we get the team up of the Sentry
Groot seems to be wearing a bulletproof
vest nebula Dawning the yandu duster and
attitude with the arrow hovering at
attention then my man Howard the Duck
and Rambo gear and corgs right right so
we all look cool nebula uses the arrow
like yandu on the ship coming for
everybody and then yonr is backing his
outfit from Captain Marvel cork smashes
Saul and yonr like H did Loki in The
Avengers movie Nova Prime jumps into the
classic Nova Starship to get away from
nebula like an idiot Nova Prime dies the
shield opens and the sun allows the
light back in it feels like the ending
of the Marvels with the cre home world
and how like it lost its smog it gained
the sun something La needs to do Howard
calls nebula Supernova which has a
little homage to it the Crab Nebula is a
supernova but also the fact that she's
the best damn Nova officer they have now
and then Howard quacks like a normal
duck and we close with this beautiful
probably digital paintings of different
parts of xandar it's incredible the
casino the Alleyways the breathtaking
images these just remind me of the
concept art from across the spiderverse
and a lot of these painters and
designers for this episode probably
created this as original concept art
that they just put in the end credits
and that's it for my breakdown on
episode one of what if nebula join the
Nova coreo I hope everybody cosplays as
this character now because she's badass
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Lulu Clemens follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching I'll see you on the next
episode
[Music]
he